good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight there's nothing more
tiresome or predictable than a cable
news host who makes the show about
himself
narcissism is to tv people what black
long is to coal miners we do our best to
avoid catching it but tonight we're
going to break our rule and tell you
about something pretty interesting that
happened to this show a couple of days
ago
on tuesday we did a segment about the
nation of ukraine now ukraine may be a
perfectly nice place to visit but you
wouldn't think it would get a lot of
attention from a superpower like this
one ukraine's a pretty small country
really it's in eastern europe it's 5 000
miles from washington it's got a
population about the size of the state
of california so hugely significant not
really
and yet we never seem to stop talking
about ukraine
as the vice president united states joe
biden himself spent an enormous amount
of his time meddling in the internal
affairs of ukraine and because of his
influence in that country his son hunter
got a job at a ukrainian company and got
rich from that
then donald trump was impeached for
speaking on the phone to an official
from yes ukraine
and now as of tonight we're moving
closer to a war over
ukraine
in the coming days russia may violate
ukraine's eastern border and this we are
told
cannot stand
in washington the territorial integrity
of the united states means precisely
nothing walls are racist we're a nation
of immigrants
but the territorial integrity of ukraine
that is something we must fight for
watch as a remarkably broad spectrum of
political figures appear on all three
cable networks to explain that if
russians cross the ukrainian border in
an undocumented caravan
we have the moral obligation to use
force immediately
we will move more nato assets closer to
russia not further away yeah if they
once again bring war to ukraine it's
just not going to be that simple i think
we should be doing a lot more and we we
shouldn't be just considering a
diplomatic track there needs to be clear
consequences for what they do because we
failed to deter and now you're inviting
conflict it's it's a it's a very bad
situation and we've we've left ourselves
without many options as a result i don't
think we're providing the deterrents
necessary to stop putin from invading
ukraine the breadbasket of russia and
it's time for the biden white house to
start speaking more clearly and more
aggressively and telling us how they're
going to stop this invasion from
happening
oh they're all red in the face but it's
not the usual partisan chorus
this is the entire choir
you just saw representatives from every
faction in washington from adam's shift
to dan crenshaw not as different as they
seem and all the dummies in between and
all of them are promoting war against
russia on behalf of our new and deeply
beloved ally the government of ukraine
vladimir putin is our most dangerous
enemy they scream we can't let them hurt
ukraine
so it turns out russiagate was actually
more effective even than we'd realized
the steele dossier has been debunked but
in washington the theme remains in force
russia russia russia russia is bad
what is this about exactly well
obviously it's the usual collection of
children falling for the usual
collection of lies but why this specific
lie
on tuesday we tried to get to the bottom
of this because it seems like it matters
we spoke to a man called clint ehrlich
as ehrlich pointed out there are a lot
of factors here driving us toward war
over ukraine but one of them
a central one is nato
so what is nato and what is the purpose
of nato since the fall of the soviet
union 30 years ago that nato was
designed as a bulwark exam against
well
no one can answer that question not one
person
and yet the same people who cooked up
the iraq war are now insisting that
ukraine must join nato anyway
that would mean putting american
military hardware right on russia's
border and russia doesn't want that any
more than we would want russian missiles
in tijuana hence the tension
now the irony as clint ehrlich pointed
out is that nato doesn't even want
ukraine to join
in other words the whole thing is nuts
it serves no american interest
whatsoever it is yet another
manufactured crisis this one devised by
restless power-hungry neocons in
washington looking for another war
here's part of what clint ehrlich told
us here we have people who are arguing
that even if the russians don't invade
ukraine that we need to invade and kick
the russians out of crimea that was an
op-ed from a senior obama administration
official this week and so i would say
that it's even simpler than that we're
dealing with our war mongers unserious
people whose policy prescriptions could
have deadly serious consequences the
deeper irony is that nato doesn't even
want ukraine that it's a corrupt country
it's more of a liability than it would
be a military asset and the people who
are pushing this simply argue that it
needs to happen because russia shouldn't
have a veto over who's in nato in other
words even when it's in our mutual
interest to not have a state in nato we
have to insist that they'll be added
just to spite the russians
well that was an interesting
conversation those seem like fair points
if they're wrong go ahead and explain
how they're wrong we'll listen
but official washington is done
explaining anything as you may have
noticed so instead the very same foreign
policy geniuses who brought slave
markets to libya went insane with rage
not since we made fun of pregnant flight
suits have they been this mad
fox host unabashedly makes putin's case
barks cnn's white house correspondent
unabashedly
shows how the disinformation successes
of russian intelligence extend way
beyond trump
tucker's island for putin noted bill
crystal a man who couldn't even run a
small circulation magazine but imagines
he should run our country's foreign
policy and then a former dnc contractor
called alexandra chalupa announced that
this show's opinions violated the law
this isn't journalism she wrote it it's
an ongoing pharah violation
tucker carlson needs to be prosecuted as
an unregistered agent of the russian
federation and treason under article 3
section 3 clause 1 of the us
constitution for aiding an enemy in
hybrid warfare against the united states
a death penalty offense
what alexandra chalupa didn't mention
speaking of pharaoh violations is that
she herself has extensive personal ties
to the ukrainian government in 2016
chalupa contacted ukraine's embassy
looking for dirt on donald trump's
presidential campaign
now she says that anyone who doesn't
believe americans should die for ukraine
must be sent to prison
virginia congressman jerry conley didn't
go that far but close he called us
right-wing agitators spewing russian
propaganda into millions of american
homes like a virus
and then congressman eric swallow of
california men who literally had sex
with a chinese spy apparently multiple
times in very strange ways agreed with
this carrying putin's water again he
wrote on twitter
and then one of barack obama's
speechwriters accused us of being quote
on the side of ethno-nationalist
authoritarianism oh ethno-nationalism so
if you don't support fighting a war on
behalf of all white ukraine against all
white russia you my friend
are a racist
and so on
so what's so interesting here is that
there was not a single argument not a
single idea in any of it
these aren't just twitter trolls these
are people who imagine themselves
foreign policy heavyweights deep
thinkers statesmen
but when challenged all they could
muster was name calling they went ad
hominem immediately because they had
nothing else they're pathetic
that ought to worry you though because
they may be pathetic they're also very
powerful
so in the end it fell to poor kamala
harris to explain why we need to fight
for the honor of ukraine and she did it
on the today show the bite
administration's forum for deep thoughts
on foreign policy here's what she said
and on the subject of ukraine i will
tell you
that the president has been very clear
and we as the united states are very
clear
if putin takes aggressive action
we are prepared to levy serious and
severe costs
period and i will tell you
that part of the the posture that we
have taken is grounded in the respect
and the value we place in sovereignty
and territorial integrity
reading her little talking points as
vehemently as she can but the best
the emphasis we place the value we place
on territorial integrity borders
sovereignty the right to determine who
comes into your country and when
that's the word from kamala harris the
lifelong open borders activist
so how should putin handle this well
putin had a better imagination
apparently he doesn't he'd paint the
russian tanks now masked on the
ukrainian border with the slogan no
person is illegal
what would kamala harris say to that on
what grounds would she tell russians who
just want a better life with their
families in ukraine that they can't come
to ukraine
if the russians just quoted emma lazarus
kamala harris would have to back off and
support them and their voting rights in
ukraine
but unfortunately for them the russians
are just too literal for this when they
invade a country this go ahead and call
it an invasion
but you still have to wonder invasion or
not why is any of this a profound
concern of ours why would you even
consider risking american lives or
sending billions of dollars to stop it
there are multiple borders
wars underway around the world there are
multiple just on the continent of africa
right now there always have been many
are dying in those wars
and yet kamala harris is not agitating
for american troops to congo
how come
we can only speculate about that
what we do know is that the
administration's russia policy would
only make sense if your goal was to
gravely hurt the united states of
america
already we have spent nearly four
billion dollars in aid to ukraine over
the last few years much of it for
weapons the point of this is to tweak
russia and if necessary to kill russians
our elites feel very superior about this
morally they brag about it constantly
so it's an up it's a win for them
but what about the cost to the rest of
us and to our country
china is the preeminent threat to the
united states nothing comes close to the
threat that china poses here's the truth
the us military impressive as it is is
not big enough to engage meaningfully
simultaneously in europe and in asia
can't do both at the same time so our
attention to ukraine by definition
detracts from our attention to china
but worse and more dangerous than that
more dangerous than anything it drives
the russians into an alliance of
convenience of necessity with the
chinese government
so here you have our two biggest rivals
united united not simply against our
military
but against our
currency when the u.s dollar is
displaced as the world's reserve
currency and when that happens this
country will become poor overnight
this what you're watching now will be
one of the reasons why it happened
so it's hard to imagine anything more
significant or destructive than what
these people are doing right now it's
not just about ukraine it's about our
future hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else